untangling our membership from the eu is
a form of high-stakes
diplomatic gymnastics fraught with risk
hence the backstop for northern ireland
which some see as safety net and others
as a way of tying us up in knots
the back stops a bit like a venn diagram
so when england scotland wales and
northern ireland are within the eu
they have the same regulations external
tariffs with no internal tariffs
but if they pull apart there's a
conundrum to allow frictionless movement
to the republic of ireland
from northern ireland they'd need to
maintain regulations and tariffs from
the eu
but that would create a border in the
irish sea with the rest of the uk
but if northern ireland pulls away with
the uk
then it creates a land border with
ireland so the process of separation
appears to require you to choose between
the two options
the backstop blurs this it keeps the
whole of the uk in a customs union
with the eu while northern ireland is
more closely linked and also remains in
the single market
some argue this would be an indefinite
bind
locks us in we have no vote to leave the
eu will not negotiate with us fairly
they will force us towards it and they
will get the concessions and we will be
in a very difficult position and worst
of all
the dup simply can't accept it so we
don't have a government
legal text from the attorney general
advised the backstop could endure
indefinitely
but easy movement across this border is
particularly sensitive because it is
fundamental to the good friday agreement
that ended the troubles in northern
ireland the irish and the eu side have
always maintained that the backstop in
its current form is the only way to
protect the spirit of the good friday
agreement
by keeping the irish border open no
matter what which was
essentially the foundation on which the
good friday agreement was built
so what can theresa may do i will be
seeking legal and political assurances
she could ask for a form of binding
legal text
to sit alongside the backstop agreement
it could either commit the eu to
negotiating a free trade arrangement
within a specified time
or have a simple time limit to the
backstory but the eu could argue
then it is no longer a backstop the eu
can say
that he hopes this backstop is
short-term and not forever
but it's actually like to be rather
long-term because so far nobody's
thought of a way of
avoiding the need for controls on that
uh
border between the northern ireland and
the south of ireland except with the
backstop
but unless theresa may can get a real
concession on the backstop she's going
to require major acrobatics to get her
deal
through parliament jason farrell sky
news